So, the different kinds of Transparency, which you might consider versus Access
transparency. That is, it's a particular computational or
data resource which the application requires available locally or remotely and
in particular does the application need to know whether it's local or
remote. If it's Access transparent the application doesn't need to know.
Extending this is the idea of Location transparency. Is it necessary to know
the physical location of a resource. Third, is Migration transparency, that is,
can we move a resource from one. Physical machine to another, in such
a way that the rest of the system doesn't have to know that it's moved. This can
be tricky of course, if you're in the middle of using a resource when it moves,
there's the possibility that, your interaction is going to be inconsistent, or
even break. And finally, Replication transparency. One way for
dealing with reliability issues is Replication. At one extreme would
be Database Replication, where all of your data is in more than one place, and
if your, one of your databases go down, at least you have the other one there.
Okay, and then as far as Transparency is concerned, is your
application aware that there are multiple database servers in that situation.